my mince mince mince mince mince mince
mince meat pie mincemeat pies just
reminds me of like a sad orphan I
haven't decided if meat should be in
pies except chicken pot pie I know that
mince just means like finely ground
right it's like Sweeney Todd right it's
Evan Sweeney Todd he puts humans in
there um dude I haven't seen the movie
you just spoiled it oh it's cute it's
like Honey I Shrunk the kid wait this is
this is a mincemeat pie is this salt is
it sugar you licked it and we're gonna
have to share it sorry
so like is it like dessert where's the
meat
you don't like it oh it's raising that
raisins it's not even me wait is there
meat in this with the raisins just like
a pumpkin spice latte that's better than
it smells
this is like a gourmet pop-tart it's
like a Fig Newton so there's no meat
unless I hope there wasn't is this just
to say that I'm an idiot
honey trying to kill Sam you can have it
should not be called mince meat should
change to like raisin shortbread here
have some ice cream cake and it's
actually filled with salmon like why did
you Jill needs an ice cream cake I mean
the British should have given us so many
wonderful things like Doctor Who but
then I questioned it when I eat this the
mincemeat pies were surprisingly
delicious oh my god I sound like such an
idiot right I didn't know but I just
started dating this guy and he's gonna
know that you don't know what immense
meat guys